you know I was I was thinking that was a
very nice entrance that Jamie Lee Curtis
made on the helicopter and it was a very
nice reception and it occurred to me
this is the second award show in a month
at which she has received a warm hand
ladies gentlemen here to present the
award for art direction is one of
Hollywood's most talented couples please
welcome Tim Robbins and Susan Sarandon
pay attention I'm sure they're pissed
off about something
actually Dave you're right I just like
to take a brief moment of your time
something we'd like to say Susan the
nominees the best achievement in art
direction are bullets over Broadway art
direction by Santa Lucas no set
direction by Susan boda Forrest Gump
art direction by Rick Carter set
direction by Nancy Hey
interview with a vampire our direction
by Dante Ferretti set decoration by
Francesca lo Schiavo legends of the fall
art direction by Lilly Kilvert set
direction by dory Cooper the madness of
King George art direction by Ken Adams
set decoration by Carolyn Scott
and the Oscar goes to Ken Adam from the
madness of King George and Fassett
separation Carolyn
well I'm deeply honored by the Academy
and I'm really very very moved I would
like to thank in particular a very
wonderful first-time film director
Nicholas Hytner who had an incredible
concept and also obviously Alan Bennett
with a incredible screenplay and the
whole cast of the madness of George who
were superb and it was and an incredible
adventure for me to work on this film
thank you all of you